On porte tous des écouteurs, des casques
et on peut abîmer nos oreilles à cause
d'un usage qui n'est pas nécessairement
adapté.
Je vais donc vous présenter aujourd'hui
les 7 erreurs qui abîment vos oreilles et
bien évidemment vous dire comment les
corriger.
Le constat est simple, on passe
énormément de temps avec un casque ou des
écouteurs sur les oreilles.
Que ce soit dans les transports en
commun, que ce soit au travail, à la
maison, télétravail, le soir quand on
regarde des films, des séries, bref on a
beaucoup trop longtemps quelque chose sur
nos oreilles.
S'il vous arrive d'avoir une sensation
d'oreille bouchée, d'avoir un sifflement,
des acouphènes ou des douleurs aux
oreilles, c'est que vous abimez vos
oreilles.
Il faut faire attention.
D'autant plus que les constructeurs nous
poussent à utiliser toujours plus des
écouteurs.
Notamment avec la fonction speak to chat.
Vous avez vos écouteurs, vous arrivez et
vous commencez à parler.
Cela vous permet de converser, de
récupérer le son extérieur grâce au micro
et de parler normalement avec quelqu'un.
Alors que normalement, il suffirait
d'enlever ses écouteurs pour parler à
quelqu'un...
Attention, il y a énormément de risques.
C'est parti pour les 7 erreurs qui
abîment vos oreilles.
Première erreur, vous écoutez trop fort
dans un environnement bruyant et vous ne
baissez jamais le volume.
Ça m'arrive à moi aussi, on a tendance à
monter le son pour venir couvrir le bruit
ambiant.
Le problème c'est que ça envoie beaucoup
trop de son dans vos oreilles et au bout
d'un moment ça va finir par les
endommager...
Je vous conseille de prendre un bon
casque avec une réduction de bruit active.
Votre casque va
annuler une partie des sons extérieurs.
Cela vous évitera de monter le son pour
compenser ce bruit extérieur.
Pensez à baisser régulièrement le volume.
On a tendance lorsqu'on écoute de la
musique à monter le son.
"J'adore ce morceau, je vais monter le
volume".
Et à un moment on arrive à un niveau
beaucoup trop fort.
Et qui finit par endommager vos oreilles.
Pensez régulièrement à baisser le son.
Je baisse un peu, je baisse un peu et à
la fin vos oreilles vous diront merci.
Et pensez bien évidemment à adapter le
volume à l'environnement sonore d'une
pièce.
S'il n'y a pas de bruit, ça ne sert à
rien de monter le son.
Écoutez doucement, prenez soin de vos
oreilles et ça c'est extrêmement
important.
Deuxième erreur qu'on fait tous, on ne
fait pas de pause ou trop peu de pause.
On écoute beaucoup trop longtemps la
musique et vous ne laissez pas vos
oreilles récupérer.
Ici, c'est super important de faire des
pauses.
Si vous stimulez en permanence vos
oreilles avec un signal sonore très très
proche, des écouteurs ou un casque, au
bout d'un moment, elles ont besoin de se
reposer pour venir récupérer.
C'est normal.
Comme vous, lorsque vous passez la
journée à faire du sport, courir,
travailler, ou que sais-je encore, vous
avez besoin de dormir et de récupérer.
Pour vos oreilles, c'est pareil.
Sauf qu'elles auront davantage besoin de
silence, de repos, si vous leur mettez du
son tout le temps dans les oreilles.
Pensez à faire une pause de 30 minutes
toutes les deux heures d'écoute.
Toutes les deux heures c'est déjà
relativement long.
Encore mieux lorsque vous écoutez 45
minutes de musique, vous faites un quart
d'heure de pause.
Une fois de plus, ce soit avec les
podcasts, la musique, on a tout le temps
des écouteurs sur les oreilles.
Il faut penser à les enlever.
Enlevez-les de temps en temps.
Ca évitera réellement d'endommager vos
oreilles...
Troisième erreur qu'on fait bien souvent,
on achète des écouteurs de mauvaise
qualité.
Et oui, on n'a pas forcément les moyens
de venir acheter les derniers Bose ou les
derniers Sony à 250, 300 euros avec une
bonne réduction de bruit active.
Il existe de très belles alternatives un
peu moins chères.
Je vous ai parlé il n'y a pas longtemps
des Huawei Freebuds
Pro 3 qui coûtent moins de 200 euros et
qui sont très bien.
Mais si on a un budget encore plus
réduit, moins de 100 euros.
Des fois, on achète vers des marques qui
ne sont pas bonnes.
Et si vous les achetez sur Temu,
AliExpress ou que sais-je encore, vous
vous retrouviez avec des écouteurs avec
un son un peu trop medium.
Lorsque vous allez monter le son, ça
viendra agresser vos oreilles et ça c'est
pas terrible.
Des fois il vaut mieux dépenser un peu
plus d'argent pour augmenter la qualité
sonore, avoir une bande de fréquence un
peu plus large.
Ainsi si vous montez un peu plus le son,
vous allez éviter d'écouter trop des
fréquences médiums et endommager vos
oreilles.
N'achetez pas de contrefaçon.
Il y a un
très gros marché de la contrefaçon.
Les AirPods sont les écouteurs les plus
copiés au monde.
Vous trouverez énormément de copies sur
différents sites.
Pensez à acheter des marques connues,
reconnues, sérieuses qui fabriqueront des
écouteurs ou des casques dans les règles
de l'art.
Comme ça vous êtes sûr que vous n'allez
pas non plus flinguer vos oreilles avec
des écouteurs de très mauvaise qualité.
Quatrième erreur qu'on fait quasiment
tous, on n'écoute qu'au travers de ses
écouteurs ou de son casque.
On perd trop souvent l'habitude d'écouter
au travers des haut-parleurs.
Les haut-parleur d'un smartphone, vous me
direz c'est pas très bon, le son n'est pas
terrible.
Je suis d'accord mais si vous utilisez un
ordinateur, mettez de la musique sur votre
ordinateur.
Pourquoi pas si vous êtes en télétravail,
utilisez une enceinte plutôt qu'un casque.
On a souvent tendance lorsqu'on
télétravaille à faire des
vidéoconférences, à parler avec son boss,
ses collègues ...
C'est quand même très pratique d'avoir un
casque.
Comme ça vous pouvez switcher de votre
téléphone à votre ordinateur ...
c'est simple.
Mais ce n'est pas bon pour vos oreilles
qui ont besoin à un moment de faire une
pause, qu'on retire un casque, qu'on leur
enlève des écouteurs et utiliser des
haut-parleurs sur un ordinateur, utiliser
une enceinte pour écouter de la musique.
Croyez-moi, ça a vraiment du bon.
Cinquième erreur, c'est plus une erreur
liée à la santé.
Utiliser les écouteurs trop fermés va
venir poser un problème par rapport à
l'écoulement du cérumen.
On a trop souvent tendance à penser que
le cérumen c'est dégueulasse, c'est une
espèce de cire dans les oreilles, on n'en
veut pas pour autant.
Le cérumen vient
protéger vos oreilles des bactéries, des
insectes et c'est un système auto
nettoyant de vos oreilles qui va venir
s'écouler.
Lorsque vous mettez trop longtemps des
écouteurs dans vos oreilles ça va bloquer
forcément la circulation de l'air et pour
autant on a tous besoin de cette
circulation de l'air qui va permettre de
laisser le cérumen fluide et qui lui
permettra de s'écouler.
Lorsque vous bouchez vos oreilles trop
longtemps ça va bloquer la circulation de
l'air et ça va faire sécher le cérumen
qui ne va pas s'écouler naturellement...
à terme ça va créer des bouchons, vous
entendrez moins bien, vous aurez tendance
à mettre le son un peu plus fort, bref
c'est pas bon.
En plus de ça, le fait de bloquer le
cérumen pourra créer une inflammation dans
vos oreilles, et ça on n'a pas envie.
Le fait d'avoir ce bouchon de cérumen ça
va emprisonner de la sueur et de
l'humidité dans vos oreilles qui va être
propice aux infections fongiques ou encore
bactériennes, c'est pas bien.
Si vous utilisez un casque, vous aurez
moins ce problème qui sera un peu plus
respirant.
Si vous utilisez par exemple des Airpods
classiques d'Apple, ça ne viendra pas
enfermer votre oreille, il n'y aura pas
de problème.
Vous pouvez également utiliser des
écouteurs Sony qui seront perforés et
qui...
ne poseront pas de problème par rapport à
la circulation de l'air.
Mais si vous utilisez trop longtemps des
intras,
vous risquez d'avoir un problème avec
l'écoulement de votre cérumen.
6ème
erreur, vous vous endormez avec vos
écouteurs et ce n'est pas bon.
On est très nombreux à dormir avec ses
écouteurs.
Beaucoup de personnes le soir ont envie
d'écouter un podcast,
de l'ASMR,
de la musique pour pouvoir s'endormir.
Sauf que lorsque vous avez du monde à la
maison, c'est pas évident de le mettre sur
une enceinte.
Et bien souvent, on vient le mettre au
travers d'écouteurs.
Ce qui veut dire que vous êtes à tête sur
l'oreiller, vous avez vos écouteurs et
vous commencez à vous endormir...
Mais même si vous vous endormez, vos
oreilles ne dorment pas car elles ont
toujours de la musique ou du son.
Pendant combien de temps cela va durer la
nuit ?
Cela veut dire que vous cumulez l'écoute
de la journée plus l'écoute la nuit
lorsque vous dormez.
Vous ne laissez jamais vos oreilles se
reposer.
Cela va être extrêmement préjudiciable.
C'est une
mauvaise idée.
7ème erreur qu'on fait quasiment tous, on
prend beaucoup trop ses appels
téléphoniques avec un casque ou avec des
écouteurs.
Ce que je fait pour résoudre ce problème,
c'est prendre mon téléphone et de
téléphoner avec mes haut-parleurs.
Lorsque vous travaillez en open space et
qu'il y a beaucoup de monde autour de vous
ou encore dans la rue, dans un café...
c'est pas très facile.
Mais lorsque vous en avez la possibilité,
isolez-vous, répondez à vos appels sur
haut-parleurs, ça sera quand même bien
meilleur pour vos oreilles.
Je vous donne quelques astuces en plus
pour prendre soin de vos oreilles.
Prenez du temps pour vous sans aucun
bruit.
Je le fais très souvent lorsque je suis
dans les transports en commun.
Je prends un casque à réduction de bruit,
je mets la réduction de bruit sans aucune
musique et je me coupe du son extérieur.
Ça permet à mes oreilles d'être calmes,
de se relaxer, de se reposer dans des
environnements très bruyants.
C'est quand même vachement bien.
Vous coupez un peu, ça c'est cool, ça
vous met un peu dans votre bulle, ça vous
isole et ça permet à vos oreilles de se
reposer.
Et ça, pour le coup, c'est vraiment
intéressant...
La méthode la moins chère, si vous n'avez
pas d'écouteurs, c'est de prendre des
boules QUIES.
Ça marche bien aussi.
Deuxième astuce
intéressante, c'est la règle des 60-60.
Ce qu'on vous recommandera ici, c'est de
venir écouter pendant 60 minutes maximum à
60% du volume.
Ne montez pas à 100%, ça ne sert à rien.
Ne vous abîmez pas les oreilles.
Pas plus de 60 minutes.
Et comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
pensez bien évidemment à faire des pauses.
3ème astuce,
pensez à nettoyer vos écouteurs.
Quand on regarde les écouteurs
à l'intérieur, on voit que c'est un peu
sale.
Si c'est du cérumen, c'est pas grave.
Ce que vous risquez d'avoir à terme, ce
sont des pathogènes que vous allez
retrouver sur vos écouteurs.
Dans le cas d'intra, vous allez mettre
directement vos pathogènes dans les
oreilles.
Et ça, c'est pas bon...
Ça veut donc dire que vous allez emmener
des bactéries directement à l'intérieur de
vos oreilles.
Bien évidemment le cérumen est là pour
tout nettoyer en s'écoulant naturellement,
mais on n'a pas envie d'emmener des
pathogènes dans nos oreilles, on n'a pas
envie de prendre de risques d'infection.
Donc pensez de temps en temps à les
nettoyer, vous éviterez tous les
problèmes.
Aujourd'hui je vous parle d'oreilles mais
il y a également 7 erreurs qu'on fait trop
souvent et qui viennent abîmer nos yeux
lorsqu'on regarde des écrans.
La vidéo est juste là, allez la voir,
vous m'en direz des nouvelles.